Великобританія…
Франція…
Німеччина…
Італія…
За лічені дні президент Володимир Зеленський здійснив цілий тур Європою,
відвідавши з почасти несподіваними візитами головних партнерів України.
Як пояснив сам Зеленський, його закордонні візити, серед іншого,
були присвячені створенню коаліції країн-партнерів,
у межах якої Україні будуть надані винищувачі західного зразка.
Про це він заявив під час спілкування з представниками ЗМІ
за результатами переговорів із федеральним канцлером Німеччини Олафом Шольцом у Берліні.
Та чи вдалося Зеленському досягнути своїх цілей?
Візит українського президента до Німеччини став знаковим -
з огляду на не найпростіші відносини між Києвом і Берліном.
І це при тому, що Німеччина стала одним із ключових постачальників зброї Україні
та прийняла понад мільйон біженців.
Ми знаємо, що німецько-українським відносинам завдано шкоди - німецькою політикою.
Наявна серйозна втрата довіри до Німеччини, яка виникла через дуже повільні постачання зброї,
через не найвдалішу інформаційну політику, в тому числі і з боку канцлера…
Так минулої весни німецька громадськість вимагала, а федеральний уряд зволікав -
як у питаннях санкцій, так і в питаннях постачання зброї.
Союзники та тодішній посол України Андрій Мельник
жорстко критикували Берлін за нерішучість,
а українська сторона навіть відмовилася приймати у Києві президента Німеччини Штайнмаєра.
Через його нібито лояльне ставлення до Росії.
Тепер же Німеччина відправляє в Україну сучасні танки та системи ППО,
навчає українських військових поводитися із західними системами озброєнь.
Загальна сума військової допомоги з боку ФРН вже перевищила 1 мільярд євро.
Відносини України та Німеччини за останні місяці покращилися після того,
як Німеччина оголосила про готовність надати Україні танки Леопард-2 останньої моделі.
А також системи ППО Іріс-Т та зенітні установки Гепард.
І цим серйозно підтримати Збройні Сили України.
Думаю, що Зеленський, після того конфлікту з президентом Штайнмаєром,
розуміє, наскільки важлива Німеччина, і наскільки ключову роль у ЄС вона грає,
щоб мобілізувати допомогу з боку ще більшої кількості країн.
Без Німеччини це було б неможливо.
Про те, що Німеччина зрештою стала локомотивом Європи у справі постачання ЗСУ зброї,
засвідчив новий масштабний пакет військової допомоги Україні,
про який у Берліні оголосили напередодні візиту Зеленського.
Йдеться про ще 30 танків Leopard та додатково 20 бронетранспортерів Marder.
Окрім бронетехніки ЗСУ отримає 18 колісних гаубиць,
ще чотири системи протиповітряної оборони IRIS-T-SLM,
дванадцять пускових установок та сотні керованих ракет.
У списку також - до двохсот розвідувальних безпілотників,
сто броньованих бойових машин і понад сто машин логістичної підтримки.
Все - аби посилити ЗСУ.
Весь цей пакет військової допомоги Берлін обіцяє надати у найближчі тижні та місяці.
Загальна вартість озброєння - близько двох мільярдів семисот мільйонів євро.
Все буде взято не із запасів Бундесверу, а спеціально закуплено для ЗСУ.
За даними видання Spiegel, пакет узгодили під час секретних переговорів
між міністерствами та відомством федерального канцлера.
Акцент військової допомоги зробили на посилення сухопутних військ
та модернізацію протиповітряної оборони України.
Тож під час свого візиту до Берліна Володимир Зеленський
щиро подякував Німеччині, "любому Олафу" (як він тепер називає канцлера Шольца)
та німецькому народові за найпотужніший пакет допомоги від початку вторгнення РФ,
зауваживши, що Німеччина є надійним союзником.
Щоправда, прагнення отримувати винищувачі для ЗСУ Олаф Шольц коментувати не став,
ухилившись від прямих запитань журналістів.
Нові пакети військової допомоги Києву пообіцяли і в Парижі.
Вони включатимуть засоби ППО і десятки броньованих машин і легких танків.
Про це стало відомо зі спільної заяви президентів України та Франції:
до Еммануеля Макрона Зеленський полетів відразу з Німеччини.
Крім національного внеску, Франція бере активну участь у заходах Європейського Союзу та НАТО
щодо підготовки українських військових.
Хоч у Парижі й виключають поставку будь-яких бойових літаків до Києва,
про те Франція готова "вже зараз" розпочати підготовку українських пілотів.
У цьому Еммануель Макрон запевнив уже наступного дня після зустрічі з Зеленським.
Зустріч з прем'єр-міністром Великобританії Ріші Сунаком стала завершальною в  європейському турі Зеленського.
Однак саме оголошені напередодні та в її межах поставки мають неабияке значення в довгостроковій перспективі.
Йдеться передусім про далекобійні ракети Storm Shadow
з радіусом ураження приблизно 250 кілометрів.
Здатні нести боєприпас вагою у приблизно 450 кілограмів,
ці ракети схожі за характеристиками з американськими ATACMS
наземного базування, про які давно просить Київ.
Крім того, Великобританія надасть сотні ракет протиповітряної оборони,
а також нових безпілотних авіаційних систем,
в тому числі сотні нових ударних безпілотників дальнього радіусу дії.
Сполучене Королівство оголосило про надання крилатих ракет Storm Shadow,
що дійсно говорить про зміну потужностей.
Ще одне оголошення, яке, ймовірно, є більш значущим на військовому фронті, -
це кілька сотень безпілотників.
Цікаво те, що це частина програми, яку Великобританія розробляє для швидкої реалізації.
Вони мають велику дальність - 200 кілометрів.
А це, по-перше, надасть Україні здатність завдавати ударів далеко за лінії розташування військ РФ.
Але що ще важливіше, у стратегічному плані оголошення про поставки Storm Shadow,
британських крилатих ракет та безпілотників чинить тиск на США,
щоб вони почали надавати свої ракети великої дальності.
Так само, як раніше британські поставки 14 танків Challenger
торували шлях європейським та американським танками.
Тож це насправді суттєвий крок з точки зору здатностей України.
Лондон також заявив про готовність принаймні сприяти наданню ЗСУ винищувачів F-16.
У самої Великобританії їх на озброєнні немає.
А вже влітку британці розпочнуть анонсовану ще в лютому підготовку українських пілотів
для використання ними західних бойових літаків.
Навіть якщо ніщо з обіцяних нових поставок не встигне надійти ЗСУ
до початку очікуваного контрнаступу, "євротур" Зеленського
можна оцінювати як успіх, вважають опитані DW експерти.
Адже його головною метою було передусім забезпечення сталості військової підтримки
й поставок техніки з боку європейських партнерів.
Це важливі візити не тільки тому, що президент Зеленський
зміцнює особисті стосунки з канцлером Шольцем,
президентом Макроном та прем'єр-міністром Сунаком,
але й тому, що він виступає на публіці в цих країнах перед німецькими та британськими платниками податків,
які вже багато - з їхньої точки зору - зробили для підтримки України.
І вони бачать Зеленського, чують його слова подяки і це, безумовно,
допоможе йому отримати подальшу підтримку.
Я був в Україні кілька тижнів тому, слухав українських командувачів і політичних лідерів,
і вони роблять фокус на сталості поставок, на тому, щоб зберегти підтримку.
Є навіть інформація, що Україна планує інші наступи після цього навесні і влітку,
якщо це можна так назвати.
І для цього, звичайно, їм знадобиться безперебійне постачання.
Гадаю, найцікавіше в цій поїздці, що Зеленський відвідав цілу низку європейських столиць,
таким чином продемонструвавши, що велика четвірка найбільших економічно потужних європейських країн
готові надавати підтримку Україні не лише в короткостроковій, а й у середньостроковій перспективі.
Підтримати, ймовірно, не один очікуваний контрнаступ.
Сам Зеленський залишився задоволений своїм європейським турне,
хоч і не повернувся в Україну з винищувачами.
За словами президента, Україна й західні партнери ще мають "трохи попрацювати"
над передачею західних винищувачів.
Оглядачі вважають вірогідність поставок Заходом бойових літаків високою.
Доти ж варто використовувати час для підготовки,
перш ніж поспіхом йти у контрнаступ, радять експерти.
Підготовка військових частин, які повинні будуть здійснити цей контрнаступ - це вимагає часу.
Розумно використовувати цей час насамперед для підготовки солдатів.
У них буде лише одна можливість і розумно відпрацьовувати взаємодію
між різними видами зброї якнайкраще,
а також берегти ресурси доти, поки не буде достатньо для успішного наступу.
Контрнаступ не буде раптовим і блискавичним,
розуміють західні партнери України.
Вони готові й надалі допомагати Україні в розв'язаній Росією війні.